welcome to this video playing Thomas
Tallis from from Italy ok I played the
Dutch last time and got clobbered let's
do something something solid this time
the will Queens gambit declined ok
capture on f6 that's a slightly out of
fashion nowadays for a white but of
course not a bad line and was featured
very very prominently in the cup of
power of matches in the 1980s of course
um 97 I'm not sure about the precise
move order here need to prepare c5 I
should Android did I need to play it
early am whom yeah not not totally sure
a 6b five is I'm is a slightly ambitious
way to to to handle this line there are
more reliable ways to play against it
but this is an interesting little bit
sharp away maybe can go d5 here hmm
Queen seat or something it's not a
problem we should be seven
t5 d5 looks irritating or maybe I can
play if I've just closing things and
Bishop d6 not ideal well he's thinking
about it understandable it's a it says
it's a slightly critical it's a slightly
critical decision Jim I cannot really
let him take bishop be 7d is six Bishop
before it takes g7 mmm but but this is
still wide if he takes the seven I have
to shove d6 right so I get it back at
the end so maybe this is in fact still
okay but should be seven d6 Bishop
before ed seven Bishop d7 and I'm taking
it next move I think why not have him
principal and Queen takes Queen takes
again bishop and I hope I'm writing if
I've was also possible closing things
but this is definitely more principled
if it is working I think y term probably
must take here check here
and here I thought I can actually think
about be sure before first we should be
four and then moved back to d6 Jack and
prevent him from canceling right II to
Queen d7 sss of course excellent for
black so we must play this and now i'm
dropping back not totally sure that kini
tours move that is a problem for a wide
but and I'm getting b7 back this was my
rationale when they play Bishop d7 I'm
not sure maybe 27 was more critical even
okay over here I need to take off this
limb or not yeah I guess so no no tricks
or anything and play 95 but I've Queen
f5 getting into a self pen now must my
see Paul is backward not ideal I need to
need to activate maybe if you go here
you can play work deform it's not cannot
cannot really take g 2 hoops you monster
this is not good but I get peers more
pieces into play and here probably need
to get this off a eight so that my rook
can actually move okay he's doubling
doubling 95 schnapps and really coming
on
hmm maybe before I will be five
something like that I don't know need to
increase my speed iam
Jeff from a structural point of view
this doesn't look right for me but maybe
I've am active enough don't know not not
quite sure what might be just better
I don't really get anything against his
King taking some time him I don't really
know what my plan is I stopped playing a
sister connection issue no wow
it does not show a connection issue and
maybe maybe he still lost I had some
problem I don't know doorbell or
anything at this a shame this is an
interesting very interesting position I
guess white should be better here lots
of endgame types are favorable for YTM
and now is playing okay lots of endgame
times as mentioned up a favorable for
wine ok wanted to activate the rook like
that so let's do it and this is stupid
Queen age three I was thinking Queen g4s
stupid but here I'm setting up a
self-penned again okay I can give the
check he I am check can give this check
it's quite the cord need um okay there's
some sound tactic maybe some tactic
going on some tactic b3 and Bishop
before maybe
you should see how we can take our f5 I
mean you can take
I want to get in somehow look Kix look
everyone i'm buying this possible hmm i
don't i don't really see something right
here i can trade but that's not maybe
this scent queen d 50 I don't know
attacking a to ng to sort of a double
attack winning a pawn maybe I guess I'll
take this check okay active Queen at
least I didn't see that you can take
okay he's got two seconds this is this
weird pause or whatever it was um really
really cost them more things on time
yeah but this is of course a bit um a
bit strange with this this long long
thing okay it was interesting maybe I I
screwed up the move order here i think i
am I need to play 97 here first not be
five this is probably a wrong move order
probably and here this should be 75 huh
yeah maybe I can just take it the comp
just wants to take it with equal play
yeah maybe that's true i mean i get in
c5 if this is the main thing i must be
able to play a play see 5 the only way
for him to
prevent that is to play Bishop c6 which
does not look super threatening I mean
even even this yes even this is a
possible way to play yeah no problem
really okay this is probably risky at
least takes takes Queen takes is more
dangerous yeah I I suspected that
already because it's here in this
situation it's it's much more difficult
for me to get the porn back yeah this is
good for might actually just just as
good for what you can what he does
marriage is he can set up something like
this Bishop t5 this is excellent now for
white he has a yeah this is a position
that in a way resembles the Catalan
opening where I'm very often the
queenside structure but black is a is a
problem those pawns a week and he gets
in a route to c6 for example if we look
at something like this this is just
fantastic position for white those pawns
will never ever move and some good night
maneuvers might just lead to the fall of
the pawns not sold yet on how exactly
night maybe to c5 not clear not clear
why this was what is clearly in command
I mean lots of ideas for white and I
cannot do very much can also remove the
night and then try to use this for
against free on the Kings side this is a
fantastic position four ID you know this
is yes it's not as clear maybe this also
was great but I don't know here I think
I'm still alive I mean with Queens on
it's a different matter is king is a
little bit insecure and maybe I can get
some counterplay why this certain is
still better this is nothing I'm curious
about this if there is some tactic here
aha rook age five there is some tactic
look d5 as strong it seems with the big
edge for black rook d5 yeah of course
there is this of course there is some
logic behind that now rook t4 is not
possible and black is just having a good
look at the center idea is to go here
and rook the eight putting pressure on
the night maybe Bishop f6 that's very
strong yeah very strong after that there
is not much not much going on probably
it's about equal but he had this long
time donor somehow okay thanks for
watching